Let's exercise a bit on the division of rational numbers,
or another way to think about it is -
fragmentation of fractions.
It is the same.
We have example (s), task 1.
"Find the reciprocal value
of each of the following. "
This means that if I have an 'a' number,
its reciprocal value will be 1 / a.
When I pick up a number and multiply it
on its reciprocal value, I will receive a / a,
which equals 1.
'a' at its recyclable value will be equal to 1.
Let's solve these tasks.
Example (a).
We have 100.
Reciprocal value of this
is just 1/100.
And if you multiply this, you get 1.
Example (b).
I will make all the examples.
We have 2/8.
The reciprocal of 2/8 is 1 / (2/8), which is the same thing -
this is equal to 1 on the reciprocal value of this.
By 8/2, which is the same as 4.
Now you can immediately notice something.
I guess you see a model here.
If you take 1 on a liver,
the result is that the liver is turning.
The reciprocal of 2/8 is 8/2.
You simply change the positions of the numerator and the denominator.
Let's apply this to example (c).
If I have - (19/21), its reciprocal value will simply be -
You change the positions of the numerator and the denominator.
- (21/19).
And if you multiply these two numbers,
you will get 1.
Negative characters will be destroyed.
21 and 21 will be shortened,
19 and 19 will be shortened.
Example (d).
The reciprocal of 7 - my mind began to confuse,
the reciprocal value is 1/7.
Lastly, let's solve E.
Reciprocal yields z3 on -
this is minus z ^ 3 on 2u ^ 3.
Reciprocal value of this - one of the more difficult
words for me - it will be equal to ...
this is reciprocal, it will be equal to 1 on this,
which just will be minus -
the denominator becomes a numerator -
- (2) (3) (3)
Let's move on to the next section.
"Divide the following rational numbers.
Make sure your answer is in its simplest form. "
I will solve these tasks through one,
just not to waste your whole time.
Let's do the first: example (a).
I'll do it here.
Example (a).
5/2 divided by 1/4.
It's the same as 5/2 by 4/1.
The division of something is the same as multiplication
on its reciprocal value.
I multiply by the reciprocal value of 1/4.
This will be equal to - we can divide
the numerator and the denominator of 2, so 4 becomes 2,
and 2 becomes 1.
5 by 2 is 10/1, so it's just 10.
Example (b).
Or let me decide on one.
(c)
5/11 divided by 6/7.
Again, it's the same as 5/11
by the reciprocal of 6/7, ie 7/6.
And this is 5 at 7 is 35, on 66.
And this is the simplest kind of thing.
Let's see (is).
We have - (x / 2) divided by 5/7.
Again, it is the same as - (x / 2)
7/5, which is equal to - (7x / 10).
I think it becomes clear.
Let's make an example (g).
We have - (1/3) divided by - (3/5).
This will be the same as - (1/3)
on the reciprocal of this, (5/3).
I just changed the positions of the numerator and the denominator.
This will be equal to - the negative signs are destroyed.
Negatively negative is positive.
1 in 5 is 5.
3 in 3 is 9.
Let's figure out another example.
Let us decide (i).
Example (i).
11, divided by - (x / 4).
Again, this is the same as 11
on the reciprocal of this.
Reciprocal value, by - (4 / x).
And if it confuses you -
I really do not have to write multiplication.
It looks like x.
I have to say that this is the same as 11
in (4 / x).
Or you can look at this as a 11 /
you can see this as (-4) on x,
and the total is equal to (-44) / x or - (44 / x).
Let us decide this last example.
"The world's largest excavator, Bagger 288,
is moving at 3/8 miles per hour. "
So his speed, or his agility,
is equal to 3/8 miles per hour.
We can record it like that.
Millions in the hour.
"How long will it take to the excavator
to excavate a 2/3 mile long ditch? "
We want to go a distance that is equal to 2/3 miles.
We'll just remember that the distance
is always equal to the speed of time.
Our distance is 2/3 miles.
This will be equal to the speed,
3/8 miles per hour,
at the time.
Or we can divide the two sides at 3/8 miles per hour,
if we divide the two sides at 3/8 miles per hour,
we will get the time.
We divide at 3/8 miles per hour.
These are destroyed.
We will get that time equal to that.
We have 2/3 miles.
Let me write it this way.
2/3 miles, divided by 3/8 miles per hour.
Or another way to think about it is,
that it is the same as the reciprocal,
8/3 hours per mile.
We just take the reciprocal value.
We shared this.
It is the same as multiplying by its reciprocal value.
And we also turned the units of measurement.
And we see that units of measurement are being destroyed.
Dear Milestone, Dear Milestone.
There are hours left.
And this is equal to -
2 at 8 is 16,
on 3 at 3, 9.
It's 16/9 hours.
Hour and 7/9 or 1 whole and 7/9 hours,
to dig out 2/3 of a mile.